PREENING REMINDS US OF WHY WE
ELECTED TRUMP IN THE FIRSTIX
PLACE.
THAT’S "THE ANGLE."
>> Laura: THE BIGGEST STORY IN
WASHINGTON, THE DEMOCRATS’
GOVERNMENT IF THEY DON’T GET A
DACA DEAL GIVING AMNESTY TO
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DREAMERS.
MY FIRST GUEST WAS IN THAT
INFAMOUS MEETING LAST WEEK WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP REJECTED THAT
WEAK GANG OF SIX PLAN AND
ALLEGEDLY UTTERED THE HORRIBLE
S-WORD.
THIS LAWMAKER IS ALSO OFFERED
HIS OWN DACA PLAN THAT IS STRONG
ON BORDER SECURITY, AND
IMMIGRATION EVEN FORCEMENT.
AND THE.
AND THE WHITE HOUSE COMPLIMENTED
ON JANUARY 10.
WELCOME THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, BOB
GOODLATTE IN WASHINGTON.
GREAT TO SEE YOU, CONGRESSMAN.
I KNOW YOU WEREN’T AT THE
MEETING TODAY THAT GENERAL KELLY
HAD WERE A CONGRESSIONAL
HISPANIC CAUCUS.
HE DID HAVE SOME INTERESTING
THINGS TO SAY.
I WANT TO PLAY A SOUND BITE FOR
YOU.
THIS WAS GENERAL KELLY ON BRET
BAIER TONIGHT.
LET’S WATCH.
>> THERE’S BEEN AN EVOLUTIONARY
PROCESS THAT THIS PRESIDENT HAS
GONE THROUGH.
AS A CAMPAIGN I POINTED OUT TO
THE MEMBERS IN THE ROOM THAT
THEY ALL SAY THINGS DURING THE
COURSE OF CAMPAIGNS THAT MAY OR
MAY NOT BE FULLY INFORMED.
BUT THIS PRESIDENT, IF YOU’VE
SEEN WHAT HE’S DONE, HE HAS
CHANGED THE QUAYS HE LOOKS AT A
NUMBER OF THINGS.
CAMPAIGN TO GOVERNING ARE TWO
DIFFERENT THINGS.
>> Laura: WHEN WE HEAR WORDS
LIKE EVOLVE, CONGRESSMAN, A LOT
OF TRUMP SUPPORTERS GET NERVOUS.
ON ISSUES LIKE THE WALL, MEXICO
WAS SUPPOSED TO PAY FOR IT,
WHERE ARE WE?
>> WELL, I THINK WE’RE IN A
STRONG POSITION.
GENERAL KELLY, SECRETARY
NIELSEN, DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY, HAVE BEEN UP HERE A
LOT ON CAPITOL HILL.
I WASN’T AT THE MEETING YOU
REARED TO.
-- REFERRED TO.
BUT I KNOW THEY’RE CONVEYING,
TWO MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS KEEPING HIS
COMMITMENT, BOTH WITH REGARD TO
SECURITY AT THE BORDER AND TO
MAKING SURE WHEN PEOPLE GET
ACROSS THE BORDER AND
APPREHENDED OR TURN THEMSELVES
IN THEY’RE SAFELY RETURNED HOME
AND NOT SIMPLY RELEASED INTO THE
INTERIOR OF THE COUNTRY.
WE HAVE TO END CHAIN MIGRATION.
THE PRESIDENT AS YOU NOTED HAD A
GREAT MEETING AT THE WHITE HOUSE
LAST TUESDAY.
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS GOT TO SEE
THAT ON TELEVISION LIVE OR ON
TAPE.
AND THEY KNOW THIS PRESIDENT IS
TRYING TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
BUT TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM YOU
HAVE TO STOP AND MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE RESPECT THE LAW.
THAT’S WHAT REPUBLICANS IN THE
HOUSE ARE ALL ABOUT, THAT’S WHAT
THE LEGISLATION WE HAVE
INTRODUCED IS ALL ABOUT.
YES, WE’LL DOING?
FOR THE DACA RECIPIENTS BUT WE
HAVE TO MAKE ABSOLUTELY SURE
THAT AS THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
HAS SAID, THIS SHOULDN’T BE
ALLOWED TO CONTINUE.
AND THEREFORE, WE HAVE LOTS OF
BORDER SECURITY, LOTS OF
INTERIOR ENFORCEMENT.
>> Laura: I’M GOING TO GET TO
SPECIFICALLY WHAT THAT IS.
BUT YOUR BILL, YOUR BILL, YOU
CO-AUTHORED WITH RAUL LA BRA
DOSH, NOT WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
ASKED FOR -- LABRADOR, NOT ALL
OF WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAS ASKED
FOR, TO GIVE RELEASE TO THE DACA
FOLKS.
I WANT TO PLAY A SOUND BITE FROM
MITCH McCONNELL EARLIER TODAY.
HE SEEMS CONFUSED ABOUT WHAT THE
PRESIDENT CAN SIGN.
LET’S WATCH.
>> HE’S NOT YET INDICATED WHAT
MEASURE HE’S WILLING TO SIGN.
AS SOON AS WE FIGURE OUT WHAT HE
IS FOR, THEN I WOULD BE
CONVINCED THAT WE WERE NOT JUST
SPINNING OUR WHEELS.
>> Laura: WAIT A SECOND,
SPINNING YOUR WHEELS?
ON JANUARY 10 THE WHITE HOUSE
CAME OUT IN SUPPORT OF YOUR
BILL, CONGRESSMAN.
HOW IS THAT CONFUSING FOR
SENATOR McCONNELL?
I’M NOT CLEAR ON THAT.
>> WELL, I THINK IT’S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT THE HOUSE PASS
THIS BILL SO THAT THE SENATE
SEES THAT THERE IS STRONG,
STRONG SUPPORT FOR ADDRESSING
DACA, BUT MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE STRONG BORDERS AND MAKING
SURE THAT OUR LAWS ARE
RESPECTED.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN WE KNOW
THAT.
WHY WON’T PAUL RYAN BRING THE
BILL UP FOR A VOTE?
THAT WOULD GIVE THIS WHOLE
CONVERSATION A LOT OF MOMENTUM
AND TAKE THE WIND OUT OF THE
SAILS OF THE OPEN BORDER TYPES,
SAYING OH, TRUMP IS A RACIST,
TRUMP DOESN’T WANT TO HELP THESE
PEOPLE, TRUMP USES FOUL LANGUAGE
IN THE OVAL OFFICE WE’RE GOING
TO SHUT DOWN THE GOVERNMENT.
YOUR BILL GIVES HIM WHAT HE SAID
HE WILL DO, AND A LOT OF THESE
DEMOCRATS CLAIM THEY’RE FOR
BORDER SECURITY.
THEN YOU WILL TAKE THIS OTHER
TOXIC ELEMENT OUT OF THE
EQUATION.
WHY WON’T PAUL RYAN BRING IT UP
FOR A VOTE?
>> I THINK WE ARE TAKING STEPS
IN THAT DIRECTION.
AND THE SPEAKER AND THE LEADER
HAVE BOTH INDICATED, TODAY, THAT
THEY’RE GOING TO START HAVING
MEMBER LISTENING SESSIONS TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT THIS.
>> Laura: LISTENING?
LISTEN TO THE PEOPLE.
YOU LISTEN TO THE PEEP.
.
I SOUND LIKE I’M BLOWING SMOKE
TOWARD YOU, BUT YOU LISTENED TO
THE PEOPLE IN YOUR LEGISLATION.
KELLY WAS SAYING ON BRET BAIER,
IT’S ONLY GOING TO BE 700 MILES,
I GUESS, BUT THAT’S NOT WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID, HE’S EVOLVING.
YOU AND YOUR BILL, YOU ACTUALLY
TRACKED WHAT THE PRESIDENT
CAMPAIGNED ON FOR THE MOST PART,
WITH THE DACA PIECE, HE DIDN’T
CAMPAIGN ON.
BUT I THINK PRESIDENT HAS SHOWN
HE’S MOVING TO COMPROMISE AND
ALL THE WHILE JEFF FLAKE GOES
OUT THERE, CALLS HIM ESSENTIALLY
STALIN, LINDSAY GRAHAM LEAKING
ELEMENTS OF THE MEETING.
THE NEGATIVITY IS COMING FROM
THE SAME CROWD THAT ALMOST GROVE
US DROVE US INTO THE GROUND IN
2008.
I DON’T LIKE IT.
>> I DON’T, THAT’S WHY WE’RE
PUSHING FOR BILL, THINGS ARE
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
YES, WE HAVE TO GET THE LEADER
TO BRING THIS BILL TO THE FLOOR
OF THE HOUSE.
>> Laura: HE METER DO IT.
>> WE HAVE TO DO IT.
WE HAVE TO GET THE MEMBERS
RALLYING BEHIND IT.
WE’VE BEEN WORKING HARD ON THE
BILL, NOW WE’RE EDUCATING THE
MEMBERS WHAT IS IN THE BILL.
YOUR VIEWERS CAN HELP BY LETTING
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS KNOW THAT
THEY WANT THESE IMPORTANT
SECURITY MEASURES BROUGHT TO THE
FLOOR OF THE HOUSE FOR A VOTE.
>> Laura: THEY ARE.
ENDING CHAIN MIGRATION, ENDING
VISA LOTTERY, WE HAVE PEOPLE IN
THE SENATE WANT TO JUST MOVE THE
DECK CHAIRS ON THE TITANIC AND
GIVE THE VISA LOTTERY SPOTS TO
THE TEMPORARY PROTECTED STATUS
PEEP FROM HURRICANES THAT
HAPPENED DECADES AGO, CORRECT?
>> CORRECT.
AND WE ABSOLUTELY CANNOT DO
THAT, THE HOUSE WILL NOT DO
THAT.
>> Laura: THAT’S RIDICULOUS,
NONSTARTER.
>> I DON’T THINK THE SENATE
WILL, AFTER ALL THINGS ARE SAID
AND DONE AS WELL I THINK THERE
ARE MANY, MANY SENATORS WHO ARE
GUN SHY ABOUT THAT APPROACH.
>> Laura: CONGRESS MAINE, WE
APPRECIATE YOUR JOINING US
TONIGHT AND EXPLAINING THIS TO
US.
AND I THINK A LOT OF OUR
VIEWERS, MY LISTENERS ON RADIO,
ARE JACKED UP ABOUT THIS AND
THEY KNOW WHAT FLAKE WAS UP TO